I just want to have a quick question
from you so basically you were saying at
the very beginning your question that
kind of quote-unquote blaming us by
making bad choices as women so I'm
asking you as a man if you imagine
yourself as a woman what would you say
what would an ideal Father Figure man
would look like to you
as a woman what would the Father Figure
look yeah so how would you tell if
you're a woman that this is a guy you're
dating yes that he is a father figure
time time in the background see when
you're having kids with them like are
you mean hold on hold on hold on let me
answer the question so if for me
personally I think what is the man's
moral compass yeah what is he about has
he got Ambitions is he family orientated
already does he come from a close-knit
family already like to get him saying
because if it's just a guy that you're
just attracted to because he's tall oh
my God bro like that don't mean nothing
yeah and a lot of guys are very good at
selling dreams very good you know what
I'm saying like narcissist
not even necessarily nonsense it's just
like at the end of the day it's not that
many of them it's not easy to just throw
your sausage around like do you get what
I'm saying like a lot of times women
think it's easy to sleep with loads of
guilt it's not bro like you need some
skills there unless you're just sleeping
with ducks see what I'm saying like if
you want quality you're gonna need some
skills to talk so in a way you are kind
of selling the product yourself in it
like you know what I'm saying so
so I watched um I saw this viral Tech
Talk video of a guy who basically said
like if he wants to get with an eight
nine or a ten he's gonna I'm quoting him
sell her the dream by taking her out to
a nice expensive dinner in Mayfair
paying for her and then asking her to go
back to his place and apparently his
success rate is like almost 100 how how
good-looking was he
he objectively he was above average but
that goes back like a eight yeah like a
solid a like did you look like he was a
bit tall like he had a bit higher yeah
yeah well there you go then in it yeah
what do you say like men are good at um
she sold herself for dream listen if the
guy if the guy is good looking yeah and
he's got a money Expendable income where
he can oh let's come to Mayfair RAV she
sold herself because she wants to align
herself with him
from the jump you get what I'm saying
like bro at the end of the day if she if
she really wanted something serious she
wouldn't have just gone back to the
house with him yeah I agree with my
patterned herself in the situation yeah
like you said um a lot of women they
fall for a guy for the wrong reasons
they fall for them based on what he has
not how he treats her and that's why so
many men who are six foot two they make
six figures women will like him not
because he's put effort into pursuing
her but because they're hypnotized by
those things that he had they hypnotize
with themselves
for a woman that shouldn't be enough to
lay down and obviously people do their
thing we're all human but when it's when
kids are concerned it's very selfish
from a woman because
your initial attraction to someone
does that mean they're right to put a
kid in you I know yeah I mean and that's
where I believe that
yeah so I believe that's why
there's more single mothers like your
initial question why is the rise of
single mothers but it's probably due to
that a lot of women that's what happened
not only I'm not only following Trends
yeah because they do you hear I mean
it's a girl group for example you could
be in a group of five friends two
friends would say listen you don't need
men the other three are going to go you
know what yeah she's right I don't need
it and they follow Trends but when
you're being selfish
and for the wrong reasons if you're if
you're sleeping with someone because
you're attracted you should know that
it's probably only going to go that far
so yeah for you just to clarify I'm not
excusing that behavior I'm also
explaining that a lot of women fall for
men for the wrong reasons which like you
said is wrong but this is why like now
like if you're a woman watching this and
you know what you know you have to be
more selective of why you catch feelings
for a guy okay
because I just want to add five cents to
this year one talk is cheap and everyone
can do it yeah that's what my dad told
me everybody can talk and basically
socially if we look at everyone in this
room we come from a social class so
things that we're experiencing are in
our social class
um
um also I would like to add to the
original question
um when I look at a man I look at who is
his dad who is his family what
interactions he has with women in his
own family so what's his relationship
like with his mom this is a this is an
analysis I do
um what's his relationships like with
his sisters or the closest women in his
family this will indicate to you the way
that he operates within a family then if
you I don't know if I'm going into the
into it way too deep but then when you
look at how he operates with women that
are not in his family so his female
friends or Associates
you can see what type of man you're
dealing with men know that women want to
hear things they will give you that
indication a man who respects himself
will not put himself his own body
forward as a sacrifice if he likes you
and he puts himself forward and says I'm
gonna have sex with you right as a woman
you make a conscious decision and you
and any woman in this room will vouch
for me in this a woman will not have a
child by a man she does not like even if
he's Rich poor you know whatever it
might be a woman will not have a child
by a man she doesn't like she will be
physically attractive you might have
Financial whatever
um but I would say on the man's side of
the of the spectrum you have to be picky
on who you lie with because once you lie
with that person is out of your control
and
um I think just in general in this kind
of job what do you mean it's out of your
control what do you mean once you lie
with that woman and your sperm is out oh
the guys
no no yeah so once you lie with that
woman it's out of your control and then
it affects your finances it affects your
well-being it affects your future it
could also affect but it affects the
woman though in yeah but she has more
control over that yeah I'm saying like
in the long term like it affects the
woman like do you get what I'm saying
because at the end of the day like boom
a man can get a woman pregnant yeah the
financial and potentials and stuff like
that really and truly the mankind kind
of just step away in a way you as a
woman you're stuck yeah but you remember
remember and and now you've put
limitations you put our ceiling on
certain certain potentials you've got in
life now I agree I'm saying so both
sides need to be aware of the risks and
again it goes back to what Auntie was
saying where there's a lot of incentives
for women to do this that's why they
don't ah well I'm pregnant no no but I'm
saying I would I would I would kind of
argue that point and say is it a risk
for women no it's not a risk it's a risk
for you it's a risk for a man but I'm
saying they are
um women will find that there will be
negative things that come out there's
negative I I agree there's negative
impacts for women so it affects your
well-being you know your ability to have
another partner your choices that you
can make because really as a mother the
biggest sacrifice you can make is having
a child and putting your child first and
as a parent overall a man can walk away
and that's the choice he makes but I
would love to think that when a guy has
a child he's natural response is to be a
provider for his child and a protected
to his child regardless if he likes the
woman or not some people are different
I'm saying you know I do whoa that's I
that's what I do whoa but back to your
original question the reason that women
make poor choices there's a number of
reasons I can't say I know all the
answers but I can say we romanticize men
so we already have a picture of what a
man should be and what it should be like
if you come from a family where you have
never experienced male nurturing how
would you know
how would you know what it feels like to
be loved by a man unconditionally like
what you said
how do you know what it's like to be
lifted by a man without
um condition you don't know so when you
step out into a relationship you already
have put these romanticized conditions
on a man that you barely even know it
also stops you from getting to know that
man if the man's in it for sex you're
basically blindsided yourself because
you've romanticized it I like him I like
the way you look I'm attracted you get
what I mean and that's what your focus
does so funny yeah yeah he's funny he's
so funny he addresses no no but he just
he dresses nice and he presents a
certain way so I think on both sides we
have to look at the polarization without
fathers men
uh some a lot well I say a lot of men
they fail to be men and on the women's
side they fail to understand what a man
is so you have men coming out who are
not men
women coming out looking for men who are
not men so the traits are very infantile
so you're basically looking for a boy
because that's what you know yeah and
and well I was going to say that the
saying goes that a woman doesn't know
how to love until she's been loved by a
father first yeah uh no self-respecting
woman is gonna fall in love with the
hypergamous factor because a guy takes
her up for calamari she's just going to
drop her knickers yeah yeah but it's you
know when you look at it all the things
that have been been spoken about around
this this panel a lot of it's
superficial when you remove the
superficial you have to look at what is
the Baseline my Baseline is very
different from from a lot of women your
Baseline will be a different experience
from a lot of men so
realistically if you're looking at a
partner are you looking at what they're
giving you physically or what they're
giving you emotionally or what they're
giving you mentally or are you just
looking at the romanticized version of
the man that you want him to be
that's my question
and that's why I say like so many women
are falling for the wrong men yeah
that's why you know like there's that
there's that culture now of like oh he's
bare minimum yeah he's giving me bare
minimum yeah it's because they let like
accountability is 50 50 right it's
partly on the woman because she lets the
guy get away with their minimum but yeah
it's also on the on the men too like
where they give bare minimum but at the
end of the day like if you allow that as
a woman then that is gonna happen
memo always perform to the standards so
that's what's that's the reason why men
go around sleeping around and screaming
a body count because the reality is a
man knows that he can scream his body
count and still get puss puss if women
stop sleeping with man that had high
body counts watch how everyone suddenly
becomes a priest yeah yeah yeah we have
we have that power that's feminine power
yeah we have a lot of power over men
yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible